THE ENTIRE ROBB ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL.
A SHORT TIME AGO STEVE KERR.
>> WE'RE NOT GOING TO TALK ABOUT
BASKETBALL.
NOTHING HAPPENED WITH OUR TEAM
IN THE LAST SIX HOURS.
ANY BASKETBALL QUESTIONS DON'T
MATTER.
SINCE WE LEFT SHOOT AROUND 14
CHILDREN WERE KILLED 400 MILES
FROM HERE AND A TEACHER AND IN
THE LAST TEN DAYS WE'VE HAD
ELDERLY BLACK PEOPLE KILLED IN A
SUPER MARKET IN BUFFALO.
WE HAD ASIAN CHURCH GOERS KILLED
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
NOW WE HAVE CHILDREN MURDERED AT
SCHOOL.
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO DO
SOMETHING?
I'M TIRED.
I'M SO TIRED OF GETTING UP HERE
AND OFFERING CONDOLENCES TO THE
DEVASTATED FAMILIES THAT ARE OUT
THERE.
I'M SO TIRED OF THE -- I'M
SORRY.
I'M TIRED OF THE MOMENTS OF
SILENCE.
ENOUGH.
THERE'S 50 SENATORS RIGHT NOW
WHO REFUSE TO VOTE ON HR8 WHICH
IS A BACKGROUND CHECK RULE THE
HOUSE PASSED A COUPLE YEARS AGO.
IT'S BEEN SITTING THERE FOR TWO
YEARS.
THERE'S A REASON THEY WON'T VOTE
ON IT, TO HOLD ON TO POWER.
I ASK YOU MITCH McCONNELL, I ASK
ALL YOU SENATORS WHO REFUSE TO
DO ANYTHING ABOUT THE VIOLENCE
AND SCHOOL SHOOTINGS AND
SUPERMARKET SHOOTINGS, I ASK YOU
ARE YOU GOING TO PUT YOUR DESIRE
FOR POWER AHEAD OF THE LIVES OF
OUR CHILDREN AND ELDERLY AND OUR
CHURCH GOERS?
THAT'S WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
IT'S WHAT WE DO EVERY WEEK.
SO I'M FED UP.
I'VE HAD ENOUGH.
WE'RE GOING TO PLAY THE GAME
TONIGHT, BUT I WANT EVERY PERSON
HERE, EVERY PERSON LISTENING TO
THIS TO THINK ABOUT YOUR OWN
CHILD OR GRANDCHILD OR MOTHER OR
FATHER, SISTER, BROTHER, HOW
WOULD YOU FEEL IF THIS HAPPENED
TO YOU TODAY?
WE CAN'T GET NUMB TO THIS.
WE CAN'T SIT HERE AND READ ABOUT
IT AND GO, WELL, LET'S HAVE A
MOMENT OF SILENCE.
GO DUBS.
COME ON MAVS.
LET'S GO.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO.
50 SENATORS IN WASHINGTON ARE
GOING TO HOLD US HOSTAGE.
DO YOU REALIZE THAT 90% OF
AMERICANS, REGARDLESS OF
POLITICAL PARTY, WANT UNIVERSAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS?
90% OF US.
WE ARE BEING HELD HOSTAGE BY 50
SENATORS IN WASHINGTON WHO
REFUSE TO PUT IT TO A VOTE
DESPITE WH